[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
PROFESSOR: So far in this course
we've been talking a
lot about data abstraction.
And remember the idea is that
we build systems that have
these horizontal barriers in
them, these abstraction
barriers that separate use,
the way you might use some
data object, from the way
you might represent it.
Or another way to think of that
is up here you have the
boss who's going to be using
some sort of data object.
And down here is George
who's implemented it.
Now this notion of separating
use from representation so you
can think about these two
problems separately is a very,
very powerful programming
methodology, data abstraction.
On the other hand, it's not
really sufficient for really
complex systems. And the problem
with this is George.
Or actually, the problem
is that there
are a lot of Georges.
Let's be concrete.
Let's suppose there is George,
and there's also Martha.
OK, now George and Martha are
both working on this system,
both designing representations,
and
absolutely are incompatible.
They wouldn't cooperate on a
representation under any
circumstances.
And the problem is you would
like to have some system where
both George and Martha are
designing representations, and
yet, if you're above this
abstraction barrier you don't
want to have to worry about
that, whether something is
done by George or by Martha.
And you don't want George
and Martha to
interfere with each other.
Somehow in designing a system,
you not only want these
horizontal barriers, but you
also want some kind of
vertical barrier to keep George
and Martha separate.
Let me be a little bit
more concrete.
Imagine that you're thinking
about personnel records for a
large company with a lot of
loosely linked divisions that
don't cooperate very
well either.
And imagine even that this
company is formed by merging a
whole bunch of companies that
already have their personnel
record system set up.
And imagine that once these
divisions are all linked in
some kind of very sophisticated
satellite
network, and all these databases
are put together.
And what you'd like to do is,
from any place in the company,
to be able to say things like,
oh, what's the name in a
personnel record?
Or, what's the job description
in a personnel record?
And not have to worry about the
fact that each division
obviously is going to have
completely separate
conventions for how you might
implement these records.
From this point you don't
want to know about that.
Well how could you
possibly do that?
One way, of course, is to send
down an edict from somewhere
that everybody has to change
their format to some fixed
compatible thing.
That's what people often try,
and of course it never works.
Another thing that you might
want to do is somehow arrange
it so you can have these
vertical barriers.
So that when you ask for the
name of a personnel record,
somehow, whatever format it
happens to be, name will
figure out how to do
the right thing.
We want name to be, so-called,
a generic operator.
Generic operator means what it
sort of precisely does depends
on the kind of data that
it's looking at.
More than that, you'd like to
design the system so that the
next time a new division comes
into the company they don't
have to make any big changes in
what they're already doing
to link into this system, and
the rest of the company
doesn't have to make any big
changes to admit their stuff
to the system.
So that's the problem you should
be thinking about.
Like it's sort of
just your work.
You want to be able to
include new things by
making minimal changes.
OK, well that's the problem
that we'll be
talking about today.
And you should have this sort
of distributed personnel
record system in your mind.
But actually the one I'll be
talking about is a problem
that's a little bit more
self-contained than that.
that'll bring up the issues,
I think, more clearly.
That's the problem of doing a
system that does arithmetic on
complex numbers.
So let's take a look here.
Just as a little review,
there are things
called complex numbers.
Complex number you can think
of as a point in
the plane, or z.
And you can represent a point
either by its real-part and
its imaginary-part.
So if this is z and its
real-part is this much, and
its imaginary-part is that
much, and you write z
equals x plus iy.
Or another way to represent a
complex number is by saying,
what's the distance from the
origin, and what's the angle?
So that represents a complex
number as its
radius times an angle.
This one's called-- the
original one's called
rectangular form, rectangular
representation, real- and
imaginary-part, or polar
representation.
Magnitude and angle--
and if you know the real- and
imaginary-part, you can figure
out the magnitude and angle.
If you know x and y, you can
get r by this formula.
Square root of sum of the
squares, and you can get the
angle as an arctangent.
Or conversely, if you knew
r and A you could
figure out x and y.
x is r times the cosine of A,
and y is r times the sine of
A. All right, so there's
these two.
They're complex numbers.
You can think of them
either in polar form
or rectangular form.
What we would like to do is
make a system that does
arithmetic on complex numbers.
In other words, what
we'd like--
just like the rational
number example--
is to have some operations plus
c, which is going to take
two complex numbers and add
them, subtract them, and
multiply them, and
divide them.
OK, well there's little bit
of mathematics behind it.
What are the actual formulas for
manipulating such things?
And it's sort of not important
where they come from, but just
as an implementer let's see--
if you want to add two complex
numbers it's pretty easy to
get its real-part and
its imaginary-part.
The real-part of the sum of
two complex numbers, the
real-part of the z1 plus z2 is
the real-part of z1 plus the
real-part of z2.
And the imaginary-part of z1
plus z2 is the imaginary part
of z1 plus the imaginary
part of z2.
So it's pretty easy to
add complex numbers.
You just add the corresponding
parts and make a new complex
number with those parts.
If you want to multiply them,
it's kind of nice to do it in
polar form.
Because if you have two complex
numbers, the magnitude
of their product is here, the
product of the magnitudes.
And the angle of the product
is the sum of the angles.
So that's sort of mathematics
that allows you to do
arithmetic on complex numbers.
Let's actually think about
the implementation.
Well we do it just like
rational numbers.
We come down, we assume
we have some
constructors and selectors.
What would we like?
Well let's assume that we make
a data object cloud, which is
a complex number that has some
stuff in it, and that we can
get out from a complex number
the real-part, or the
imaginary-part, or the
magnitude, or the angle.
We want some ways of making
complex numbers-- not only
selectors, but constructors.
So we'll assume we have a thing
called make-rectangular.
What make-rectangular is going
to do is take a real-part and
an imaginary-part and construct
a complex number
with those parts.
Similarly, we can have
make-polar which will take a
magnitude and an angle, and
construct a complex number
which has that magnitude
and angle.
So here's a system.
We'll have two constructors
and four selectors.
And now, just like before, in
terms of that abstract data
we'll go ahead and implement our
complex number operations.
And here you can see translated
into Lisp code just
the arithmetic formulas
I put down before.
If I want to add two complex
numbers I will make a complex
number out of its real-
and imaginary-parts.
The real part of the complex
number I'm going to make is
the sum of the real-parts.
The imaginary part of the
complex number I'm going to
make is the sum of the
imaginary-parts.
I put those together, make
a complex number.
That's how I implement complex
number addition.
Subtraction is essentially
the same.
All I do is subtract the parts
rather than add them.
To multiply two complex
numbers, I
use the other formula.
I'll make a complex number out
of a magnitude and angle.
The magnitude is going to be the
product of the magnitudes
of the two complex numbers
I'm multiplying.
And the angle is going to be the
sum of the angles of the
two complex numbers
I'm multiplying.
So there's multiplication.
And then division, division
is almost the same.
Here I divide the magnitudes
and subtract the angles.
Now I've implemented
the operations.
And what do we do?
We call on George.
We've done the use, let's
worry about the
representation.
We'll call on George and say to
George, go ahead and build
us a complex number
representation.
Well that's fine.
George can say, we'll implement
a complex number
simply as a pair that has
the real-part and the
imaginary-part.
So if I want to make a complex
number with a certain
real-part and an imaginary-part,
I'll just use
cons to form a pair, and that
will-- that's George's
representation of a
complex number.
So if I want to get out the
real-part of something, I just
extract the car,
the first part.
If I want to get the
imaginary-part, I extract the
cdr. How do I deal with the
magnitude and angle?
Well if I want to extract the
magnitude of one of these
things, I get the square root
of the sum of the square of
the car plus the square of the
cdr. If I want to get the
angle, I compute the
arctangent of
the cdr in the car.
This is a list procedure for
computing arctangent.
And if somebody hands me a
magnitude and an angle and
says, make me a complex number,
well I compute the
real-part and the
imaginary-part, or our cosine
of a and our sine of
a, and stick them
together into a pair.
OK so we're done.
In fact, what I just did,
conceptually, is absolutely no
different from the rational
number representation that we
looked at last time.
It's the same sort of idea.
You implement the operators,
you pick a representation.
Nothing different.
Now let's worry about Martha.
See, Martha has a
different idea.
She doesn't want to represent a
complex number as a pair of
a real-part and an
imaginary-part.
What she would like to do is
represent a complex number as
a pair of a magnitude
and an angle.
So if instead of calling up
George we ask Martha to design
our representation, we get
something like this.
We get make-polar.
Sure, if I give you a magnitude
and an angle we're
just going to form a pair that
has magnitude and angle.
If you want to extract the
magnitude, that's easy.
You just pull out the
car or the pair.
If you want to extract the
angle, sure, that's easy.
You just pull out the cdr.
If you want to look for
real-parts and imaginary-parts,
well then you
have to do some work.
If you want the real-part, you
have to get r cosine a.
In other words, r, the car of
the pair, times the cosine of
the cdr of the pair.
So this is r times
the cosine of a,
and that's the real-part.
If you want to get the
imaginary-part, it's r times
the sine of a.
And if I hand you a real-part
and an imaginary-part and say,
make me a complex number
with that real-part and
imaginary-part, well I figure
out what the magnitude and
angle should be.
The magnitude's the square root
of the sum of the squares
and the angle's the
arctangent.
I put those together
to make a pair.
So there's Martha's idea.
Well which is better?
Well if you're doing a lot of
additions, probably George's
is better, because you're doing
a lot of real-parts and
imaginary-parts.
If mostly you're going to be
doing multiplications and
divisions, then maybe Martha's
idea is better.
Or maybe, and this is the real
point, you can't decide.
Or maybe you just have to let
them both hang around, for
personality reasons.
Maybe you just really
can't ever decide
what you would like.
And again, what we would really
like is a system that
looks like this.
That somehow there's George
over here, who has built
rectangular complex numbers.
And Martha, who has polar
complex numbers.
And somehow we have operations
that can add, and subtract,
and multiply, and divide, and it
shouldn't matter that there
are two incompatible
representations of complex
numbers floating around
this system.
In other words, not only like
an abstraction barrier here
that has things in it like
a real-part, and an
imaginary-part, and magnitude,
and angle.
So not only is there an
abstraction barrier that hides
the actual representation from
us, but also there's some kind
of vertical barrier here that
allows both of these
representations to
exist without
interfering with each other.
The idea is that the
things in here--
real-part, imaginary-part,
magnitude, and angle--
will be generic operators.
If you ask for the real-part,
it will worry about what
representation it's
looking at.
OK, well how can we do that?
There's actually a really
obvious idea, if you're used
to thinking about
complex numbers.
If you're used to thinking
about compound data.
See, suppose you could just tell
by looking at a complex
number whether it
was constructed
by George or Martha.
In other words, so it's not that
what's floating around
here are ordinary, just complex
numbers, right?
They're fancy, designer
complex numbers.
So you look at a complex numbers
as it's not just a
complex number, it's got a label
on it that says, this
one is by Martha.
Or this is a complex
number by George.
Right?
They're signed.
See, and then whenever we looked
at a complex number we
could just read the label, and
then we'd know how you expect
to operate on that.
In other words, what
we want is not just
ordinary data objects.
We want to introduce the
notion of what's
called typed data.
Typed data means, again, there's
some sort of cloud.
And what it's got in it is an
ordinary data object like
we've been thinking about.
Pulled out the contents, sort
of the actual data.
But also a thing called a
type, but it's signed by
either George or Martha.
So we're going to go from
regular data to type data.
How do we build that?
Well that's easy.
We know how to build clouds.
We build them out of pairs.
So here's a little
representation that supports
typed data.
There's a thing called take a
type and attach it to a piece
of contents, and we
just use cons.
And if we have a piece of typed
data, we can look at the
type, which is the car.
We can look at the contents,
which is the cdr. Now along
with that, the way we use our
type data will test, when
we're given a piece of data,
what type it is.
So we have some type
predicates with us.
For example, to see whether
a complex number is one of
George's, whether it's
rectangular, we just check to
see if the type of that is the
symbol rectangular, right?
The symbol rectangular.
And to check whether a complex
number is one of Martha's, we
check to see whether the type
is the symbol polar.
So that's a way to test
what kind of number
we're looking at.
Now let's think about
how we can use that
to build the system.
So let's suppose that George
and Martha were off working
separately, and each of them
had designed their complex
number representation
packages.
What do they have to do to
become part of the system, to
exist compatibly?
Well it's really pretty easy.
Remember, George had
this package.
Here's George's original
package, or half of it.
And underlined in red are the
changes he has to make.
So before, when George made a
complex number out of an x and
y, he just put them together
to make a pair.
And the only difference is
that now he signs them.
He attaches the type,
which is the symbol
rectangular to that pair.
Everything else George does
is the same, except that--
see, George and Martha both
have procedures named
real-part and imaginary-part.
So to allow them both to exist
in the same Lisp environment,
George had changed the names
of his procedures.
So we'll say, this is George's
real-part procedure.
It's the real-part rectangular
procedure, the imaginary-part
rectangular procedure.
And then here's the rest
of George's package.
He'd had magnitude and angle,
just renames them magnitude
rectangular and angle
rectangular.
And Martha has to do basically
the same thing.
Martha previously, when she made
a complex number out of a
magnitude and angle,
she just cons them.
Now she attaches the type polar,
and she changes the
name so her real-part procedure
won't conflict in
name with George's.
It's a real-part-polar,
imaginary-part-polar,
magnitude polar, and
angle polar.
Now we have the system.
Right there's George
and Martha.
And now we've got to get some
kind of manager to look at
these types.
How are these things actually
going to work now that George
and Martha have supplied
us with typed data?
Well what we have are a bunch
of generic selectors.
Generic selectors for complex
numbers real-part,
imaginary-part, magnitude,
and angle.
Let's look at them
more closely.
What does a real-part do?
If I ask for the real part
of a complex number,
well I look at it.
I look at its type.
I say, is it rectangular?
If so, I apply George's real
part procedure to the contents
of that complex number.
This is a number that
has a type on it.
I strip off the type
using contents and
apply George's procedure.
Or is this a polar
complex number?
If I want the real part, I
apply Martha's real part
procedure to the contents
of that number.
So that's how real part works.
And then similarly there's
imaginary-part, which is
almost the same.
It looks at the number and
if it's rectangular, uses
George's imaginary-part
procedure.
If it's polar, uses Martha's.
And then there's a magnitude
and an angle.
So there's a system.
Has three parts.
There's sort of George, and
Martha, and the manager.
And that's how you get generic
operators implemented.
Let's look at just a simple
example, just to pin it down.
But exactly how this is going to
work, suppose you're going
to be looking at the complex
number who's real-part is one,
and who's imaginary-part
is two.
So that would be one plus 2i.
What would happen is up here,
up here above where the
operations have to happen,
that number would be
represented as a pair of 1 and
2 together with typed data.
That would be the contents.
And the whole data would be
that thing with the symbol
rectangular added onto that.
And that's the way that complex
number would exist in
the system.
When you went to take the
real-part, the manager would
look at this and say, oh
it's one of George's.
He'll strip off the type
and hand down to
George the pair 1, 2.
And that's the kind of data
that George developed his
system to use.
So it gets stripped down.
Later on, if you ask George to
construct a complex number,
George would construct some
complex number as a pair, and
before he passes it back up
through the manager would
attach the type rectangular.
So you see what happens.
There's no confusion
in this system.
It doesn't matter in the least
that the pair 1, 2 means
something completely different
in Martha's world.
In Martha's world this pair
means the complex number whose
magnitude is 1 and
whose angle is 2.
And there's no confusion,
because by the time any pair
like this gets handed back
through the manager to the
main system it's going to have
the type polar attached.
Whereas this one would have the
type rectangular attached.
OK, let's take a break.
[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
We just looked at
a strategy for
implementing generic operators.
That strategy has a name: it's
called dispatch type.
And the idea is that you
break your system
into a bunch of pieces.
There's George and Martha, who
are making representations,
and then there's the manager.
Looks at the types on the data
and then dispatches them to
the right person.
Well what criticisms can we
make of that as a system
organization?
Well first of all there was this
little, annoying problem
that George and Martha had to
change the names of their
procedures.
George originally had a
real-part procedure, and he
had to go name it real-part
rectangular so it wouldn't
interfere with Martha's
real-part procedure, which is
now named real-part-polar, so it
wouldn't interfere with the
manager's real-part procedure,
who's now named real-part.
That's kind of an annoying
problem.
But I'm not going to talk
about that one now.
We'll see later on when we think
about the structure of
Lisp names and environments that
there really are ways to
package all those so-called name
spaces separately so they
don't interfere with
each other.
Not going to think about
that problem now.
The problem that I actually
want to focus on is what
happens when you bring somebody
new into the system.
What has to happen?
Well George and Martha
don't care.
George is sitting there in his
rectangular world, has his
procedures and his types.
Martha sits in her
polar world.
She doesn't care.
But let's look at the manager.
What's the manager have to do?
The manager comes through and
had these operations.
There was a test
for rectangular
and a test for polar.
If Harry comes in with some new
kind of complex number,
and Harry has a new type, Harry
type complex number, the
manager has to go in and change
all those procedures.
So the inflexibility in the
system, the place where work
has to happen to accommodate
change, is in the manager.
That's pretty annoying.
It's even more annoying when you
realize the manager's not
doing anything.
The manager is just being
a paper pusher.
Let's look again at these
programs. What are they doing?
What does real-part do?
Real-part says, oh, is it the
kind of complex number that
George can handle?
If so, send it off to George.
Is it the kind of complex number
that Martha can handle?
If so, send it off to Martha.
So it's really annoying that the
bottleneck in this system,
the thing that's preventing
flexibility and change, is
completely in the bureaucracy.
It's not in anybody who's
doing any of the work.
Not an uncommon situation,
unfortunately.
See, what's really going on--
abstractly in the system,
there's a table.
So what's really happening is
somewhere there's a table.
There're types.
There's polar and rectangular.
And Harry's may be over here.
And there are operators.
There's an operator
like real-part.
Or imaginary-part.
Or a magnitude and angle.
And sitting in this table are
the right procedures.
So sitting here for the type
polar and real-part is
Martha's procedure
real-part-polar.
And over here in the table
is George's procedure
real-part-rectangular.
And over here would be, say,
Martha's procedure
magnitude-polar, and
George's procedure
magnitude-rectangular,
right, and so on.
The rest of this table's
filled in.
And that's really
what's going on.
So in some sense, all the
manager is doing is acting as
this table.
Well how do we fix our system?
How do you fix bureaucracies
a lot of the time?
What you do is you get
rid of the manager.
We just take the manager and
replace him by a computer.
We're going to automate
him out of existence.
Namely, instead of having the
manager who basically consults
this table, we'll have our
system use the table directly.
What do I mean by that?
Let's assume, again using data
abstraction, that we have some
kind of data structure
that's a table.
And we have ways of sticking
things in and ways of getting
things out.
And to be explicit, let me
assume that there's an
operation called "put." And put
is going to take, in this
case two things I'll call
"keys." Key1 and key2.
And a value.
And that stores the value in the
table under key1 and key2.
And then we'll assume there's
a thing called "get," such
that if later on I say, get me
what's in the table stored
under key1 and key2, it'll
retrieve whatever value was
stored there.
And let's not worry about how
tables are implemented.
That's yet another data
abstraction, George's problem.
And maybe we'll see later--
talk about how you might
actually build tables in Lisp.
Well given this organization,
what did George and Martha
have to do?
Well when they build their
system, they each have the
responsibility to set
up their appropriate
column in the table.
So what George does, for
example, when he defines his
procedures, all he has to do
is go off and put into the
table under the
type-rectangular.
And the name of the operation
is real-part, his procedure
real-part-rectangular.
So notice what's going
into this table.
The two keys here are symbols,
rectangular and real-part.
That's the quote.
And what's going into the table
is the actual procedure
that he wrote, real-part
rectangular.
And then puts an imaginary part
into the table, filed
under the keys rectangular-
and imaginary-part, and
magnitude under the keys
rectangular magnitude, angle
under rectangular-angle.
So that's what George has to do
to be part of this system.
Martha similarly sets
up the column and
the table under polar.
Polar and real-part.
Is the procedure
real-part-polar?
And imaginary-part, and
magnitude, and angle.
So this is what Martha has to
do to be part of the system.
Everyone who makes a
representation has the
responsibility for setting
up a column in the table.
And what does Harry do when
Harry comes in with his
brilliant idea for implementing
complex numbers?
Well he makes whatever procedure
he wants and builds
a new column in this table.
OK, well what happened
to the manager?
The manager has been automated
out of existence and is
replaced by a procedure
called operate.
And this is the key procedure
in the whole system.
Let's say define operate.
Operate is going to take an
operation that you want to do,
the name of an operation, and an
object that you would like
to apply that operation to.
So for example, the real-part
of some particular complex
number, what does it do?
Well the first thing it does,
it looks in the table.
Goes into the table and tries
to find a procedure that's
stored in the table.
So it gets from the table, using
as keys the type of the
object and the operator, but
looks on the table and sees
what's stored under the type
of the object and the
operator, sees if anything's
stored.
Let's assume that get
is implemented.
So if nothing is stored there,
it'll return the empty list.
So it says, if there's actually
something stored
there, if the procedure here is
not no, then it'll take the
procedure that it found in the
table and apply it to the
contents of the object.
And otherwise if there was
nothing stored there, it'll--
well we can decide.
In this case let's have it put
out an error message saying,
undefined operator.
No operator for this type.
Or some appropriate
error message.
OK?
And that replaces the manager.
How do we really use it?
Well what we say is we'll go
off and define our generic
selectors using operate.
We'll say that the real-part
of an object is found by
operating on the object with
the name of the operation
being real-part.
And then similarly,
imaginary-part is operate
using the name imaginary-part
and magnitude and angle.
That's our implementation.
That plus the tape plus
the operate procedure.
And the table effectively
replaces what the
manager used to do.
Let's just go through that
slowly to show you
what's going on.
Suppose I have one of Martha's
complex numbers.
It's got magnitude
1 and angle 2.
And it's one of Martha's.
So it's labeled here, polar.
Let's call that z.
Suppose that's z.
And suppose with this
implementation someone comes
up and asks for the
real-part of z.
Well real-part now is defined
in terms of operate.
So that's equivalent to saying
operate with the name of the
operator being real-part, the
symbol real-part on z.
And now operate comes.
It's going to look in the table,
and it's going to try
and find something
stored under--
the operation is going to apply
by looking in the table
under the type of the object.
And the type of z is polar.
So it's going to look and say,
can I get using polar?
And the operation name,
which was real-part.
It's going to look in there
and apply that to
the contents of z.
And that?
If everything was set up
correctly, this thing is the
procedure that Martha
put there.
This is real-part-polar.
And this is z without
its type.
The thing that Martha originally
designed those
procedures to work on,
which is 1, 2.
And so operate sort of does
uniformly what the manager
used to do sort of all
over the system.
It finds the right thing, looks
in the table, strips off
the type, and passes
it down into the
person who handles it.
This is another, and, you can
see, more flexible for most
purposes, way of implementing
generic operators.
And it's called data-directed
programming.
And the idea of that is in some
sense the data objects
themselves, those little complex
numbers that are
floating around the system,
are carrying with them the
information about how you
should operate on them.
Let's break for questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What do you have
stored in that data object?
You have the data itself, you
have its type, and you have
the operations for that type?
Or where are the operations
that you found?
PROFESSOR: OK, let me--
yeah, that's a good question.
Because it raises other
possibilities of how
you might do it.
And of course there are a
lot of possibilities.
In this particular
implementation, what's sitting
in this data object, for
example, is the data itself--
which in this case is
a pair of 1 and 2--
and also a symbol.
This is the symbol, the word
P-O-L-A-R, and that's what's
sitting in this data object.
Where are the operations
themselves?
The operations are sitting
in the table.
So in this table, the rows and
columns of the table are
labeled by symbols.
So when I store something in
this table, the key might be
the symbol polar and the
symbol magnitude.
And I think by writing it this
way I've been very confusing.
Because what's really
sitting here isn't--
when I wrote magnitude polar,
what I mean is the procedure
magnitude polar.
And probably what I really
should have written--
except it's too small
for me to write
in this little space--
is something like lambda
of z, the thing that
Martha wrote to implement.
And then you can see from that,
there's another way that
I alluded to of solving this
name conflict problem, which
is that George and Martha
never have to name their
procedures at all.
They can just stick the
anonymous things generated by
lambda directly into
the table.
There's also another thing that
your question raises, is
the possibility that maybe what
I would like somehow is
to store in this data object not
the symbol P-O-L-A-R but
maybe actually all the
operations themselves.
And that's another way to
organize the system, called
message passing.
So there are a lot of
ways you can do it.
AUDIENCE: Therefore if Martha
and George had used the same
procedure names, it would be
OK because it wouldn't look
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
See, they wouldn't even
have to name their
procedures at all.
What George could have written
instead of saying put in the
table under rectangular- and
real-part, the procedure
real-part rectangular, George
could have written put under
rectangular real-part, lambda
of z, such and such,
and such and such.
And the system would work
completely the same.
AUDIENCE: My question is, Martha
could have put key1
key2 real-part, and George
could have put key1 key2
real-part, and as long as they
defined them differently they
wouldn't have had any
conflicts, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that would all
be OK except for the fact that
if you imagine George and Martha
typing at the same
console with the same meanings
for all their names, and it
would get confused by real-part,
but there are ways
to arrange that, too.
And in principle you're
absolutely right.
If their names didn't
conflict--
it's the objects that go in
the table, not the names.
OK, let's take a break.
[MUSIC-- "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]
All right, well we just looked
at data-directed programming
as a way of implementing a
system that does arithmetic on
complex numbers.
So I had these operations in it
called plus C and minus C,
and multiply, and divide,
and maybe some others.
And that sat on top of-- and
this is the key point-- sat on
top of two different
representations.
A rectangular package here,
and a polar package.
And maybe some more.
And we saw that the whole idea
is that maybe some more are
now very easy to add.
But that doesn't really show the
power of this methodology.
Shows you what's going on.
The power of the methodology
only becomes apparent when you
start embedding this in some
more complex system.
What I'm going to do now is
embed this in some more
complex system.
Let's assume that what we really
have is a general kind
of arithmetic system.
So called generic arithmetic
system.
And at the top level here,
somebody can say add two
things, or subtract two things,
or multiply two
things, or divide two things.
And underneath that there's
an abstraction barrier.
And underneath this barrier,
is, say, a
complex arithmetic package.
And you can say, add two
complex numbers.
Or you might also have--
remember we did a rational
number package-- you might
have that sitting there.
And there might be
a rational thing.
And the rational number package,
well, has the things
we implemented.
Plus rat, and times
rat, and so on.
Or you might have ordinary
Lisp numbers.
You might say add
three and four.
So we might have ordinary
numbers, in which case we have
the Lisp supplied plus, and
minus, and times, and slash.
OK, so we might imagine this
complex number system sitting
in a more complicated generic
operator structure at
the next level up.
Well how can we make that?
We already have the
idea, we're just
going to do it again.
We've implemented a rational
number package.
Let's look at how it
has to be changed.
In fact, at this level
it doesn't have to
be changed at all.
This is exactly the code that
we wrote last time.
To add two rational
numbers, remember
there was this formula.
You make a rational number
whose numerator--
the numerator of the first times
the denominator of the
second, plus the denominator
of the first times the
numerator of the second.
And who's denominator is the
product of the denominators.
And minus rat, and star
rat, and slash rat.
And this is exactly the rational
number package that
we made before.
We're ignoring the GCD problem,
but let's not worry
about that.
As implementers of this rational
number package, how
do we install it in the generic
arithmetic system?
Well that's easy.
There's only one thing we
have to do differently.
Whereas previously we said that
to make a rational number
you built a pair of the
numerator and denominator,
here we'll not only build the
pair, but we'll sign it.
We'll attach the
type rational.
That's the only thing we have
to do different, make it a
typed data object.
And now we'll stick our
operations in the table.
We'll put under the symbol
rational and the operation add
our procedure, plus rat.
And, again, note this
is a symbol.
Right?
Quote, unquote, but the actual
thing we're putting in the
table is the procedure.
And for how to subtract,
well you subtract
rationals with minus rat.
And multiply, and divide.
And that is exactly and
precisely what we have to do
to fit inside this generic
arithmetic system.
Well how does the whole
thing work?
See, what we want to do is have
some generic operators.
Have add and sub and
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
be generic operators.
So we're going to define add and
say, to add x and y, that
will be operate--
we were going to call
it operate-2.
This is our operator procedure,
but set up for two
arguments using add
on x and y.
And so this is the analog
to operate.
Let's look at the
code for second.
It's almost like operate.
To operate with some operator
on an argument 1 and an
argument 2, well the first thing
we're going to do is
check and see if the two
arguments have the same type.
So we'll say, is the type of the
first argument the same as
the type of the second
argument?
And if they're not, we'll go
off and complain, and say,
that's an error.
We don't know how to do that.
If they do have the same
type, we'll do
exactly what we did before.
We'll go look and filed under
the type of the argument--
arg 1 and arg 2 have the same
type, so it doesn't matter.
So we'll look in the table,
find the procedure.
If there is a procedure there,
then we'll apply it to the
contents of the argument 1 and
the contents of arg 2.
And otherwise we'll
say, error.
Undefined operator.
And so there's operate-2.
And that's all we have to do.
We just built the complex
number package before.
How do we embed that complex
number package in
this generic system?
Almost the same.
We make a procedure called
make-complex that takes
whatever George and Martha
hand to us and add the
type-complex.
And then we say, to add complex
numbers, plus complex,
we use our internal procedure,
plus c, and attach a type,
make that a complex number.
So our original package had
names plus c and minus c that
we're using to communicate
with George and Martha.
And then to communicate with the
outside world, we have a
thing called plus-complex
and minus-complex.
And so on.
And the only difference
is that these return
values that are tight.
So they can be looked
at up here.
And these are internal
operations.
Let's go look at that
slide again.
There's one more thing we do.
After defining plus-complex, we
put under the type complex
and the symbol add, that
procedure plus complex.
And then similarly for
subtracting complex numbers,
and multiplying them,
and dividing them.
OK, how do we install
ordinary numbers?
Exactly the same way.
Come off and say, well we'll
make a thing called
make-number.
Make-number takes a number and
attaches a type, which is the
symbol number.
We build a procedure called
plus-number, which is simply,
add the two things using the
ordinary addition, because in
this case we're talking about
ordinary numbers, and attach a
type to it and make
that a number.
And then we put into the table
under the symbol number and
the operation add, this
procedure plus-number, and
then the same thing for
subtracting, and multiplying,
and dividing.
Let's look at an example,
just to make it clear.
Suppose, for instance,
I'm going
to perform the operation.
So I sit up here and I'm going
to perform the operation,
which looks like multiplying
two complex numbers.
So I would multiply, say,
3 plus 4i and 2 plus 6i.
And that's something that
I might want to take
hand that to mul.
I'll write mul as my generic
operator here.
How's that going to work?
Well 3 plus 4i, say, sits in
the system at this level as
something that looks
like this.
Let's say it was one
of George's.
So it would have a 3 and a 4.
And attached to that would be
George's type, which would say
rectangular, it came
from George.
And attached to that--
and this itself would be the
data view from the next level
up, which it is--
so that itself would be a
type-data object which would
say complex.
So that's what this object would
look like up here at the
very highest level, where
the really super-generic
operations are looking at it.
Now what happens, mul
eventually's going to come
along and say, oh,
what's it's type?
It's type is complex.
Go through to operate-2 and say,
oh, what I want to do is
apply what's in the table,
which is going to be the
procedure star complex, on
this thing with the type
stripped off.
So it's going to strip off the
type, take that much, and send
that down into the
complex world.
The complex world looks at its
operations and says, oh, I
have to apply star c.
Star c might say, oh, at some
point I want to look at the
magnitude of this object that
it's in, that it's got.
And they'll say, oh, it's
rectangular, it's one of George's.
So it'll then strip off the next
version of type, and hand
that down to George to take
the magnitude of.
So you see what's going
on is that there are
these chains of types.
And the length of the chain is
sort of the number of levels
that you're going to be going
up in this table.
And what a type tells you, every
time you have a vertical
barrier in this table, where
there's some ambiguity about
where you should go down to the
next level, the type is
telling you where to go.
And then everybody at the
bottom, as they construct data
and filter it up, they stick
their type back on.
So that's the general structure
of the system.
OK.
Now that we've got this, let's
go and make this thing even
more complex.
Let's talk about adding to the
system not only these kinds of
numbers, but it's also
meaningful to start talking
about adding polynomials.
Might do arithmetic
on polynomials.
Like we could have x to the
fifteenth plus 2x to the
seventh plus 5.
That might be some polynomial.
And if we have two such gadgets
we can add them or
multiply them.
Let's not worry about
dividing them.
Just add them, multiply them,
then we'll subtract them.
What do we have to do?
Well let's think about how we
might represent a polynomial.
It's going to be some
typed data object.
So let's say a polynomial to
this system might look like a
thing that starts with
the type polynomial.
And then maybe it says the
next thing is what
variable its in.
So I might say I'm a polynomial
in the variable x.
And then it'll have some
information about
what the terms are.
And there're just tons of ways
to do this, but one way is to
say we're going to have a thing
called a term-list. And
a term-list--
well, in our case we'll
use something
that looks like this.
We'll make it a bunch of pairs
which have an order in a
coefficient.
So this polynomial would be
represented by this term-list.
And what that means is that
this polynomial starts off
with a term of order 15
and coefficient 1.
And the next thing in it is
a term of order 7 and
coefficient 2, a term of order
0, which is constant in
coefficient 5.
And there are lots and lots of
ways, and lots and lots of
trade-offs when you really think
about making algebraic
manipulation packages about
exactly how you should
represent these things.
But this is a fairly
standard one.
It's useful in a lot
of contexts.
OK, well how do we implement
our polynomial arithmetic?
Let's start out.
What we'll do to make
a polynomial--
we'll first have a way
to make polynomials.
We're going to make a polynomial
out of variable
like x and term-list. And all
that does is we'll package
them together someway.
We'll put the variable together
with the term list
using cons, and then attached
to that the type polynomial.
OK, how do we add
two polynomials?
To add a polynomial, p1 and
p2, and then just for
simplicity let's say
we will only add
things in the same variable.
So if they have the same
variable, and same variable
here is going to be some
selector we write, whose
details we don't care about.
If the two polynomials have the
same variable, then we'll
do something.
If they don't have the same
variable, we'll give an error,
polynomials not in the
same variable.
And if they do have the same
variable, what we'll do is
we'll make a polynomial whose
variable is whatever that
variable is, and whose term-list
is something we'll
call sum-terms. Plus terms will
add the two term lists.
So we'll add the two term
lists to the polynomial.
That'll give us a term-list.
We'll add on, we'll say it's a
polynomial in the variable
with that
term-list. That's plus poly.
And then we're going to put in
our table under the type
polynomial, add them
using plus poly.
And of course we really
haven't done much.
What we've really done is pushed
all the work onto this
thing, plus-terms, which is
supposed to add term-lists.
Let's look at that.
Here's an overview of how we
might add two term-lists.
So L1 and L2 were going
to be two term-lists.
And a term-list is a bunch of
pairs, coefficient in order.
And it's a big case analysis.
And the first thing we'll check
for and see if there are
any terms. We're going to
recursively work down these
term-lists, so eventually we'll
get to a place where
either L1 or L2 might
be empty.
And if either one is empty,
our answer will
be the other one.
So if L1 is empty we'll return
L2, and if L2 is empty
we'll return L1.
Otherwise there are sort of
three interesting cases.
What we're going to do is grab
the first term in each of
those lists, called t1 and t2.
And we're going to look at
three cases, depending on
whether the order of t1 is
greater than the order of t2,
or less than t2, or the same.
Those are the three cases
we're going to look at.
Let's look at this case.
If the order of t1 is greater
than the order of t2, then
what that means is that our
answer is going to start with
this term of the order of t1.
Because it won't combine with
any lower order terms. So what
we do is add the lower order
terms. We recursively add
together all the terms
in the rest of the
term-list in L1 and L2.
That's going to be the lower
order terms of the answer.
And then we're going to
adjoin to that the
highest order term.
And I'm using here a whole bunch
of procedures I haven't
defined, like a adjoin-term, and
rest-terms, and selectors
that get order.
But you can imagine
what those are.
So if the first term-list has
a higher order than the
second, we recursively add all
the lower terms and then stick
on that last term.
The other case, the same way.
If the first term has a smaller
order, well then we
add the first term-list and the
rest of the terms in the
second one, and adjoin on
this highest order term.
So so far nothing's much
happened, we've just sort of
pushed this thing off into
adding lower order terms. The
last case where you actually get
to a coefficients that you
have to add, this will
be the case where
the orders are equal.
What we do is, well again
recursively add the lower
order terms. But now we have to
really combine something.
What we do is we make a term
whose order is the order of
the term we're looking at.
By now t1 and t2 have
the same order.
That's its order.
And its coefficient is gotten
by adding the coefficient of
t1 and the coefficient of t2.
This is a big recursive working
down of terms, but
really there's only one
interesting symbol in this
procedure, only one
interesting idea.
The interesting idea
is this add.
And the reason that's
interesting is because
something completely wonderful
just happened.
We reduced adding polynomials,
not to sort of plus, but to
the generic add.
In other words, by implementing
it that way, not
only do we have our system where
we can have rational
numbers, or complex numbers,
or ordinary numbers, we've
just added on polynomials.
But the coefficients of the
polynomials can be anything
that the system can add.
So these could be polynomials
whose coefficients are
rational numbers or complex
numbers, which in turn could
be either rectangular, or polar,
or ordinary numbers.
So what I mean precisely
is our system right now
automatically can handle things
like adding together
polynomials that have this one:
2/3 of x squared plus
5/17 x plus 11/4.
Or automatically handle
polynomials that look like 3
plus 2i times x to the fifth
plus 4 plus 7i, or something.
You can automatically
handle those things.
Why is that?
That's merely because, or
profoundly because we reduced
adding polynomials to adding
their coefficients.
And adding coefficients was
done by the generic add
operator, which said, I don't
care what your types are as
long as I know how to add you.
So automatically for
free we get the
ability to handle that.
What's even better than that,
because remember one of the
things we did is we put into the
table that the way you add
polynomials is using
plus poly.
That means that polynomials
themselves are
things that can be added.
So for instance let
me write one here.
Here's a polynomial.
So this gadget here I'm
writing up, this is a
polynomial in y whose
coefficients are
polynomials in x.
So you see, simply by saying,
polynomials are themselves
things that can be added, we can
go off and say, well not
only can we deal with rationals,
or complex, or
ordinary numbers, but we can
deal with polynomials whose
coefficients are rationals, or
complex, or ordinary numbers,
or polynomials whose
coefficients are rationals, or
complex, rectangular, polar,
or ordinary numbers, or
polynomials whose coefficients
are rationals, complex, or
ordinary numbers.
And so on, and so
on, and so on.
So this is sort of an infinite
or maybe a recursive tower of
types that we've built up.
And it's all exactly from
that one little symbol.
A-D-D. Writing "add" instead
of "plus" in
the polynomial thing.
Slightly different way to
think about it is that
polynomials are a constructor
for types.
Namely you give it a type, like
integer, and it returns
for you polynomials in x whose
coefficients are integers.
And the important thing about
that is that the operations on
polynomials reduce to the
operations on the
coefficients.
And there are a lot of
things like that.
So for example, let's go back
and rational numbers.
We thought about rational
numbers as an integer over an
integer, but there's
the general notion
of a rational object.
Like we might think about 3x
plus 7 over x squared plus 1.
That's general rational object
whose numerator and
denominator are polynomials.
And to add two of them we use
the same formula, numerator
times denominator plus
denominator times numerator
over product of denominators.
How could we install
that in our system?
Well here's our original
rational
number arithmetic package.
And all we have to do in order
to make the entire system
continue working with general
rational objects, is replace
these particular pluses and
stars by the generic operator.
So if we simply change that
procedure to this one, here
we've changed plus and star
to add a mul, those are
absolutely the only change,
then suddenly our entire
system can start talking about
objects that look like this.
So for example, here is a
rational object whose
numerator is a polynomial in
x whose coefficients are
rational numbers.
Or here is a rational object
whose numerator is polynomials
in x whose coefficients are
rational objects constructed
out of complex numbers.
And then there are a lot of
other things like that.
See, whenever you have a thing
where the operations reduce to
operations on the pieces,
another example would be two
by two matrices.
I have the idea, there might
be a matrix here of general
things that I don't
care about.
But if I add two of them, the
answer over here is gotten by
adding this one and that one,
however they like to add.
So I can implement that
the same way.
And if I do that, then again
suddenly my system can start
handling things like this.
So here's a matrix whose
elements happen to be--
we'll say this element here
is a rational object whose
numerator and denominators
are polynomials.
And all that comes for free.
What's really going on here?
What's really going on is
getting rid of this manager
who's sitting there poking his
nose into who everybody's
business is.
We built a system that has
decentralized control.
So when you come into and no
one's poking around saying,
gee, are you in the
official list of
people who can be added?
Rather you say, well go off
and add yourself how your
parts like to be added.
And the result of that is you
can get this very, very, very
complex hierarchy where a lot
of things just get done and
rooted to the right place
automatically.
Let's stop for questions.
AUDIENCE: You say you
get this for free.
One thing that strikes me is
that now you've lost kind of
the cleanness of the break
between what's on top and
what's underneath.
In other words, now you're
defining some of the
lower-level procedures
in terms of things
above their own line.
Isn't that dangerous?
Or, if nothing more, a little
less structured?
PROFESSOR: No, I--
the question is whether that's
less structured.
Depends on what you
mean by structure.
All this is doing
is recursion.
See, it's saying that the
way you add these
guys is to use that.
And that's not less structured,
it's just a
recursive structure.
So I don't think it's
particularly any less clean.
AUDIENCE: Now when you want to
change the multiplier or the
add operator, suddenly you've
got tremendous consequences
underneath that you're not
even sure the extent of.
PROFESSOR: That's right, but
it depends what you mean.
See, this goes both ways.
What would be a good example?
I ignored greatest common
divisor, for instance.
I ignored that problem just to
keep the example simple.
But if I suddenly decided that
plus rat here should do a GCD
computation and install that,
then that immediately becomes
available to all of these, to
that guy, and that guy, and
that guy, and all
the way down.
So it depends what you mean by
the coherence of your system.
It's certainly true that you
might want to have a special
different one that didn't
filter down through the
coefficients, but the nice thing
about this particular
example is that mostly you do.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that the
problem, I think, that you're
getting to tied in with the fact
that the structuring, the
recursiveness of that
structuring there is actually
in execution as opposed to just
definition of the actual
types themselves?
PROFESSOR: I think I understand
the question.
The point is that these types
evolve and get more and more
complex as the thing's
actually running.
Is that what--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
As it's running.
PROFESSOR: --what
you're saying?
Yes, the point is--
AUDIENCE: As opposed to
the basic definitions.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The type structure is
sort of recursive.
It's not that you can make this
finite list of the actual
things they might look like
before the system runs.
It's something that evolves.
So if you want to specify that
system, you have to do in some
other way than by this finite
list. You have to do it by a
recursive structure.
AUDIENCE: Because the basic
structure of the types is
pretty clean and simple.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I understand once you have your
data structure set up,
how it pulls off complex and
passes that down, and then
pulls off rect, passes
that down.
But if you're just a user and
you don't know anything about
rect or polar or whatever, how
do you initially set up that
data structure so that
everything goes
to the right spot?
If I just have the equation over
there on the left and I
just want to add, multiply
complex numbers--
PROFESSOR: Well that's
the wonderful thing.
If you're just a user
you say "mul."
AUDIENCE: And it figures out
that I mean complex numbers?
Or how do I tell it
that I want--
PROFESSOR: Well you're
going to have in your
hands complex numbers.
See what you would have at some
level, as a real user, is
a constructor for
complex numbers.
AUDIENCE: So then I have to
make complex numbers?
PROFESSOR: So you have
to make them.
What you would probably have as
a user is some little thing
in the reader loop, which would
give you some plausible
way to type in a complex
number, in
whatever format you like.
Or it might be that you're
never typing them in.
Someone's just handing
you a complex number.
AUDIENCE: OK, so if I had a
complex number that had a
polynomial in it, I'd have to
make my polynomial and then
make my complex number.
PROFESSOR: Right if you wanted
it constructed from scratch.
At some point you construct
them from scratch.
But what you don't have to know
of that is when you have
the object you can just say
"mul." And it'll multiply.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think the question
that was being posed here is,
say if I want to change my
presentation of complexes, or
some operation of complex, how
much real code I will have to
gets around with, or change
to change it in
one specific operation?
PROFESSOR: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
what you have to change.
And the point is that
you only have to
change what you're changing.
See if Martha decides that
she would rather--
let's see something silly--
like change the order
in the pair.
Like angle and magnitude in
the other order, she just
makes that change locally.
And the whole thing will
propagate through the system
in the right way.
Or if suddenly you said, gee, I
have another representation
for rationals.
And I'm going to stick it
here, by filing those
operations in the table.
Then suddenly all of these
polynomials whose coefficients
are coefficients of
coefficients, or whatever,
also can automatically have
available that representation.
That's the power of this
particular one.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if I can
even pose an intelligent
sounding question.
But somehow this whole thing
went really nicely to this
beautiful finish where
all the things seemed
to fall into place.
Sort of seemed a little
contrived.
That's all for the sake,
I'm sure, of teaching.
I doubt that the guys
who first did this--
and I could be wrong--
figured it all out so that when
they just all put it all
together, you could all of the
sudden, blam, do any kind of
arithmetic on any
kind of object.
It seems like maybe they had
to play with it for a while
and had to bash it
and rework it.
And it seems like that's the
kind of problem we're really
faced with we start trying to
design a really complex
system, is having lots of
different kinds of parts and
not even knowing what kinds of
operations we're going to want
to do on those parts.
How to organize the operations
in this nice way so that no
matter what you do, when you
start putting them together
everything starts falling
out for free.
PROFESSOR: OK, well
that's certainly a
very intelligent question.
One part is this is a very good
methodology that people
have discovered a lot coming
from symbolic algebra.
Because there are a lot
of complications.
To allow you to implement these
things before you decide
what you want all the
operations to
be, and all of that.
So in some sense it's an
answer that people have
discovered by wading
through this stuff.
In another sense, it is a
very contrived example.
AUDIENCE: It seems like to be
able to do this you do have to
wade through it for a certain
amount of time before you can
become good at it.
PROFESSOR: Let me show you how
terribly contrived this is.
So you can write all these
wonderful things.
But the system that I wrote
here, and if we had another
half an hour to give this
lecture I would have given
this part of it, which says,
notice that it breaks down if
I tell it to do something as
foolish as add 3 plus 7/2.
Because what will happen is
you'll get to operate-2, and
operate-2 will say, oh
this is type number,
and that's type rational.
I don't know how to add them.
So you'd like the system at
least to be able to say
something like, gee,
before you do that
change that to 3/1.
Turn it into a rational number,
hand that to the
rational package.
That's the thing I didn't talk
about in this lecture.
It's a little bit in the book,
which talks about the problem
of what's called coercion.
Where you wanted--
see, having so carefully set
up all of these types as
distinct objects, a lot of times
you want to also put in
knowledge about how to view
an ordinary number
as a kind of rational.
Or view an ordinary number
as a kind of complex.
That's where the complexity in
the system really starts
happening, where you talk
about, see where
do I put that knowledge?
Is it rational to know that
ordinary numbers might be
pieces of [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of them?
Or they're terrible, terrible
examples, like if I might want
to add a complex number
to a rational number.
Bad example.
5/7.
Then somebody's got to know that
I have to convert these
to another type, which is
complex numbers whose parts
might be rationals.
And who worries about that?
Does complex worry about that?
Does rational worry
about that?
Does plus worry about that?
That's where the real
complexity comes in.
And that's where it's pretty
well sorted out.
And a lot of, in fact, all of
this message passing stuff was
motivated by problems
like this.
And when you really push it,
people are-- somehow the
algebraic manipulation problem
seems to be so complex that
the people who are always at the
edge of it are exactly in
the state you said.
They're wading through this
thing, mucking around, seeing
what they use, trying
to distill stuff.
AUDIENCE: I just want to come
back to this issue of
complexity once more.
It certainly seems to be true
that you have a great deal of
flexibility in altering the
lower level kinds of things.
But it is true that you are,
in a sense, freezing higher
level operations.
Or at least if you change them
you don't know where all of
the changes are going to show
up, or how they are.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's an
extremely good question.
What I have to do is, if I
decide there's a new general
operation called equality test,
then all of these people
have to decide whether or not
they would like to have an
equality test by looking
in the table.
There're ways to decentralize
it even more.
That's what I sort of hinted at
last time, where I said you
could not only have this type as
a symbol, but you actually
might store in each object
the operations
that it knows of that.
So you might have things like
greatest common divisor, which
is a thing here which is defined
only for integers, and
not in general for
rational numbers.
So it might be a very, very
fragmented system.
And then depending on where
you want your flexibility,
there's a whole spectrum
of places that you
can build that in.
But you're pointing at the place
where this starts being
weak, that there has to be some
agreement on top here
about these general
operations.
Or at least people have
to think about them.
Or you might decide, you might
have a table that's very
sparse, that only has
a few things in it.
But there are lot of ways
to play that game.
OK, thank you.
[MUSIC: "JESU, JOY OF
MAN'S DESIRING" BY
JOHANN SEBASTIAN BACH]